hi my name is peter behrens I work in
the Wolfram Alpha math content group and
I'm talking about generating
step-by-step explanations and proofs for
education
so first a little context and motivation
is this good font or should I turn it up
maybe a little bit okay got some white
space on the path so off the bat I want
to say a main purpose of this talk is to
reach out to educators and students for
ideas and feedback about how we can
improve our step-by-step coverage and
how we can use these programs in some
different ways so feel free to raise
raise questions in my top so if you
haven't seen step by step I'm going to
show you some examples in wolfram alpha
but it's a multidisciplinary effort and
then it's a blending of two very
different worlds right the highly
abstract role of math logic and
programming and the more practical world
of Education so I've been a part of both
worlds when I got my PhD in mathematical
logic I was not a lot of research
funding for set theorists so I taught
pretty much every semester and before
that and after that I've taught some
college classes in high school so I've
seen how these these worlds actually
don't interact that much and actually
they're interacting I think less and
less as mathematical theory proceeds
farther away from the basic educational
things that we teach students so a
little personal bit so maybe I should
around for a second a little personal
view of Wolfram Alpha is step by step
and homework and computer-based math
because I think it it deserves a little
to be addressed a little bit so since
we've had calculators in the classroom
students have been asking why do I have
to learn this if my calculator can do it
right and we hear this we've heard this
from the start at Wolf malva why why do
I have to do this if Wolfram Alpha can
do it and so now students with the
step-by-step can ask an even harder
question right why do I have to learn
this if not only can my computer do it
but can also understand and present an
explanation that even I can understand
right so the answer i think the
computer-based map answer is you
shouldn't write you shouldn't be
teaching your algorithms we should teach
you how to manage computational
disease and and think about big
questions and how to address them using
algorithms that you just know exists so
I'm very pro computer-based math but you
might be asking so why why are we
writing these algorithms why are we
generating these step-by-step programs
to teach these classical algorithms that
we could argue maybe students shouldn't
be learning well I see it as not
contrary to computer-based math not
exactly complementary either but sort of
maybe orthogonal so when comparison I'd
like to make is the story of of John von
Neumann who you might have known no this
story's famous for going to the backs of
math science and physics books and and
reading all the formulas and memorizing
as many formulas as he could and in that
way he could you know pick out applied
that apply different formulas and
algorithms to different research areas
and make some amazing contributions so I
see it as something like that by by
presenting these algorithms for students
in a step-by-step way automatically
we're allowing them to learn better
learn faster these algorithms and get a
better sense of what's possible oops
so it's an overview of the talk or an
overview of step by step so we had a big
role that I think in 2013 of most of our
initial step by step programs now we
have about 100 step-by-step program
spanning math physics and chemistry I
think those are the only areas covered
some of these programs are are quite
broad like step by step integrating some
of them are more specific as you'll see
so to make these programs we we've
developed a sort of informal process and
what I like to think of it as is
applying the two worlds that I thought
that I talked about in the previous
slide sort of applying one to the other
so as Stephen likes to say you know for
any for any academic field X there will
be a computational X so I guess this
will be computational pedagogy but
actually we can apply it in both ways so
it's also pedagogical computation so the
this the obvious way is that we're
making these explanations and proofs
computable by just programming the logic
of these existing methods that exist in
the standard curriculum but actually the
pedagogy informs the internal logic of
the programs that we write and sometimes
incessant eights the creation of novel
algorithm says we'll see we can use the
we can you we can bootstrap off
Mathematica to generate some of these
step-by-step programs but we'll need
some tricks to prevent Mathematica from
evaluating things too quickly which is
what it was designed to do so I'll talk
I'll I'll show you what that means in
the end but first we'll we'll go through
some examples so before some examples of
actual step by step programs just
briefly mention some ways in which the
the best computational theoretical
practice diverges from the best
educational practice so I'm not a
physicist but I think Fineman diagrams
are something that falls into this
category right a few writing a program
that computes particle interactions it's
not going to actually draw stuff and
like look at drawings internally
matrix multiplication as you may know
there's algorithms that are actually
more complicated than the standard way
and yet are faster at least for large
matrices so but so that's a case where
we don't want to teach the students of
linear algebra right the fastest way to
the best way to do it geometry proving
isn't even more interesting case because
if you want to prove something in about
a geometrical diagram the best way to do
it is to express everything in terms of
equations that is use analytic geometry
and through all these equations into
something like reduce or use some
grosvenor basis and pick out the effects
that you want from there but even in the
realm of synthetic geometry that is
axiomatic geometry there's a divergence
between the theoretical and the actual
synthetic geometry that you're taught
and usually 9th grade in the US I know
what you've other countries do but so
this is an example of a
computer-generated proof for ninth grade
geometry but in the--in the theoretical
synthetic geometry we actually reduce
the number of notions and they tend to
be somewhat more not as natural as you
think so we have things like signed area
and which is not that complicated but
some other more complicated things to
basically speed up the pen and
streamline the proofing process so let's
get to some what we'll get to some
example so but first I want to define
what our goals are for these
step-by-step programs so the first thing
to note is that the the level of the
question should indicate the level of
the response that the user expects it
should be grade level appropriate so
think of grade level sort of a proxy for
the kind of response that we're going to
give so this means that queries that are
lower level require more intuitive or
pictorial or with less jargon
explanation so an example there be if
you put in five plus nine this is
probably needs to be bigger
if you plug in five plus nine to Wolfram
Alpha you got a step-by-step result so
if this were part of a larger
step-by-step program if you had to do
five plus nine it wouldn't give you any
steps for this it would just say five
plus nine is 14 right because you're
obviously doing calculus or something
like that you know this but if you type
in five plus nine you must be a
elementary schooler so you need some
explanation for this so we actually have
to step by step programs for this one
uses a number line where you say start
at zero then you add five and then where
you are you add another nine and then
you say where am I well now i'm at the
number 14 and then there's another one
is using what are called manipulatives
which are actually physical the blocks
that you play with is my internet
working well luckily I pre-loaded most
of these
oh okay um well anyway it just I'll try
reloading but whoa okay but yeah but I
plugged it in the this thing that's okay
we can can do without it but I'll turn
it back on if I can't get it one more
time oh this is just a cache page I
don't know what's going on I don't know
ok that's ok so the manipulators are
just blocks and it says like you draw
five blocks then you draw nine blocks
next to it and then you just count the
blocks ok that there's actually it's
something like this down here so i won't
bother going to that step by step they
should be complete explanations and and
i should say with regard to number one
we as I said we skip this is showing but
five plus nine is at higher level things
but in the future we were hoping to add
a sort of give a give me some steps for
this step give me the show state the sub
steps or what do you call it show
details button so complete explanations
and of course given one and two they
should be simple direct and standard as
possible so here's some examples so
first is some of the more complex math
step by step functions and basically the
way they work is you have a list of
transformations of how you could
transform the given input and they're
applied according to some custom
heuristic so let me I don't have the
internet so I'm just go here so this is
after i press the show steps for do this
integral so here's an example where the
the standard technique says you should
do integration by parts and if you if
you recall there's a standard heuristic
for choosing which parts should be the
integral part in the derivative part so
we use that heuristic and you do it once
to
this and you get e to the 3x sine x
times the third or rather plus this
other term and again you're in the case
where usually do integration by parts so
you do integration by parts again and
then the program has to realize that
it's it's going to be an infinite loop
basically so but it should it needs to
realize that oh these two integrals are
the same so I can add them together so
it has to have algebra available to to
apply to solve this problem here's a
complicated limit so you're taking the
limit of one over X X minus one over
sine X 1 plus 1 over X to the X so
you're the transformation rule we're
going to apply is to first do some of
the limits is the limit of sums or
rather the reverse of that and to take
care of that that e term there we apply
an exponential and logarithm and then we
can move the limit inside so we're
trying to write a program that will that
will output the most common steps that a
student should be expected to to do but
there's there's some compromises you
have to make and sometimes they come in
the form of trying to compromise between
having a broad program that can do lots
of different problems if you do that say
you can or a simpler program that has
less transformation rules right could
still be just as broad but it might give
you like many many many steps and the
student might say why are you doing all
this in so many steps when you can just
use this trick or something that we
didn't include so there's there's
definitely compromises you want to make
here so we evaluate continuous functions
just do when you see an indeterminate
form apply l'hopital's rule what else
ok
so we have some simple physics formulas
actually they oops I didn't mean to
press at that time but it worked okay
okay so the way that physics simple
physics formulas work is of course you
just oh okay let me sign in there in
between so there will be a somewhere
this this piece of text will appear
right and in the code it'll it'll be
joined to these variables so it's
different in different programs so we'll
see some programs that are very sort of
simple to understand I started out with
the more complex ones but some are some
involves or transformation rules that
can do all kinds of interesting
unexpected things some are more
straightforward procedural so this just
basically separates the algebraic part
and uses a function called step-by-step
simplify to solve the numerical numeric
part but I guess first it just does the
dimensional it convert converts things
into the standard SI units so that's a
fairly straightforward one so example of
a chemistry one if you say tryptamine
structure right you get this well you
get a Wolfram Alpha output with some
pods and you press step by step and you
get step-by-step that explains how to
determine the Duluth draw the lewis
structure that's the electrons and their
their bonds between the I'm not a
chemist
so this is this is a more
straightforward procedural step-by-step
program in fact it always generates
these five steps so first it counts the
number of valence electrons and then I
councilmember valence electrons needed
to fill all the shells the outer shells
and then it applies the bonds in a way
that makes sense chemically I think
that's how it works and then finally
here's an example of a proof so if you
say prove by induction that three of the
K is greater than K to the sixth well of
course that's not always true for for lo
que so that's what this result is it's
actually proving it it's not true but
this is the more interesting case to
prove that it it is true for K greater
than 14 and please show up so really a
proof is it's not that different from
step-by-step explanation except you just
know the you know the destination and
you it has I guess more emphasis on
justification right okay well that was
my last example so I'm just going to go
on since we're close to running out of
time so I want to give you an example of
how this works for simple problems where
the where the mathematica evaluator
actually does the right thing okay so an
example of that is this really simple
example i have 3 times 2 to the 2
squared minus 3 so that'll be evaluated
by the evaluator in the by Mathematica
and the right sequence of steps which is
as you know it's called PEMDAS right you
do the parentheses and the exponents
then the order of operations I guess is
the other word for so we can hold this
query but then if we release hold it
oops right it does it all at once so
there's no way to sort of stopped in the
middle the key to understanding how to
manipulate things when they're being
held I think I think the the one sort of
key that that helps you do things like
this is this technique so if you map
something
hold it still gets held so you could see
f could itself be hold of something and
then you could release hold the outer
thing and the inner things are still
held so we're going to do something like
that and but we actually have a better
version of hold for this purpose called
inactive now I think I never officially
heard this but was it do you know if
inactive was somewhat inspired by this
thing we're doing to do step by step
programs okay okay I should have had a
step-by-step OD example as well ok so
the way inactive works is basically if
you put an active around ahead and it
won't do that head but everything else
didn't obviously here we'll evaluate and
it formats nicely in formats without
showing the inactive okay so what I want
to do is I want to put the expression in
this this form I basically want to wrap
inactive around each of the heads and I
do this with this little bit of
recursive we do here which is I'm sure
there's a much better way to do this but
this is just the way I came up with so
so now I did I have it in the form that
i want where I've inactivated each of
the heads I can just use the activate
function which activates the specific
head that I want so I'm ready to begin
my step-by-step program now I can just
first out by start out by saying there
no parentheses so let's just do the
exponents that's the e in PEMDAS so i
activate power and the two squared
became for and i have to evaluate it
again to show the to get rid of the
inactives i guess that's because we want
to see what happened to the inactives
when you do it once and so in the next
step i could just take whatever i had
here right because i said the inactive
query is the activated and active query
so it's it's still this and now I
activate the times because next we do
multiplication in order of operations so
that's where the x 34 became a 12 and
etc the next thing would be plus all the
times's it activates all the inactive x
heads so throughout it's like replace
all kind of for activate that's
interesting question and step by step
there is but I don't think so
so just to push this a little further
it's not to throw in some other
advertise some other neat functions that
we have so I'm going to use this
technique to generate a sort of problem
generator microsite so if you haven't
heard the wolfram problem generator
which which Brad Jane's talked about
it's a site where you can get unique
problems and test your test your mettle
find the solutions and of course it uses
the step by step functions once you
tried to answer the question and failed
it uses it gives you a step-by-step
explanation so that's one of the uses we
have for our step-by-step functions so
to make a problem generator really basic
one all you would need is so all you
need for your query is really your held
expression if it's just an arithmetic
query and then everything is done so ask
function i'm not going to talk all about
ass washing so don't have enough time
but really everything is done in this
one little line so this just displays
the question queue and it tests if that
if the answer the input that's what this
ask does is equal to the release hold of
q and if it is it says correct this is
the if now is evaluating and if it's not
you know it gives you a very Trump ian
wrong
so we can actually put that whole
inactivate sorry we can package the
previous slide up into a little micro
site I'd have to add cloud deploy here
but I'm not going to because of the web
problem but you could easily just deploy
this so what this one does is say enter
some math I have to say that this is
expecting a held math expression and
then what it does is displays your
answer this is now the answer whenever
you refer back to ask if you vet if
you've answered that question it just
replaces it with the value that's the
magic of ask inside ask function so
replace I should have said I don't know
why it should say enter math here I'm
not sure why it doesn't it's not doing
that but anyway let's see if it works so
I put in a problem like i was having
before say 4 times 3 to the city so this
is using the interpreter to put this
make this into a math held math
expression and then it's just going to
give me a column where I show it and
then I activate the power and then I
activate the times and then I give you
the answer hopefully I'll submit my is
it seems to be thinking a little bit
what
oh I could sir oh yeah that sometimes
happens let's see ah it oh ok I just Eve
I know what's going on I just need to do
it again I pressed it too many times
without waiting and it's gonna it's
going to ask me that many number of
times I think yes ok so that's just
packaged up that that function so thank
you and yeah I was going to give a link
to to where you can find all the step by
step functions for Wolfram Alpha but i
forgot to add that link but i will add
it if you want to download the notebook
so thanks and welcome to ask any
questions
[Applause]